foreign
[Music]
and thank you for uh for tuning in
um to me talking about one of my
favorite uh topics which is
um the bacterial immune response so
today
um I should start with introducing
myself uh my name is Aaron Whiteley I'm
an assistant professor here in the
department of biochemistry at the
University of Colorado Boulder and what
I want to talk about is uh the immune
response to pathogens and and
specifically the subject of this talk
are sea gas like enzymes in bacterial
immunity
so my lab is really interested in immune
signaling and we think about that very
broadly immune signaling really
describes the interaction between hosts
and their pathogens and when we think
about hosts we usually think about
eukaryotes we usually think about people
and how they interact with
microorganisms like bacteria fungi or
viruses but in order to understand that
interaction my lab takes a rather
unconventional approach we also study
the pathogens of some of the pathogens
I'm showing you here we study how
bacteria interact with their pathogens
which are mainly phages or the viruses
that infect bacteria
the reason we're interested in phage
bacterium interactions is because it
turns out that the immune response that
bacteria have to their phages is highly
similar to the immune response that we
have to our own pathogens in fact many
of the immune receptors in the cell that
are part of the innate immune system are
structurally homologous to immune
receptors that are in bacteria and we
take advantage of this homology to learn
about the human immune response using a
bacterial model system
I say the two are structurally
homologous and and that's because we
actually think that they diverged from a
common ancestor we don't think that this
is simply convergent evolution but
rather something that reflects a shared
evolutionary history and it's for that
reason that we think by understanding
the bacterial anti-fage response we can
understand the bacterial antiviral and
sorry the human antiviral and bacterial
immune response
so in order to give you a little better
feel for for what I mean um and also to
get to the the specific focus of today's
talk
um I want to talk about this enzyme C
gas seagas was an enzyme that was
discovered in mammals and it's a sensor
for double-stranded DNA so sea gas is in
the cytoplasm and DNA in the cytoplasm
turns out to be a really conspicuous uh
molecule telling the cell hey there's a
virus here when sea gas sees DNA it
makes seagamp and that seagamp goes on
to initiate a type 1 interferon response
via a receptor called sting and that's
why this is the sea gas sting pathway
bacteria also synthesize seagamp which
is a nucleotide second messenger and
interestingly in 2015 this enzyme dncv
was crystallized along with sea gas and
what was determined was that these two
enzymes were actually structurally
homologous so their shared ability to
make sea gamp was the result of the fact
that they're both virtually the same
structure although they share almost no
sequence identity and it's for this
reason that we call dncv a bacterial sea
gas like enzyme and this was the
beginnings of our understanding that
perhaps these two immune receptors
actually diverged from a common ancestor
I'm going to call this enzyme a CD ntas
rather than dncv and that's for sea gas
or dncv like nucleotidal transferase and
we use that term to refer to the broad
spectrum of sea gas-like enzymes that
are in bacteria when I say broad I mean
really broad over 6 500 bacterial
species in code cdntasis or sorry I
should say there are over 6 500
different alleles of of cdntases encoded
by bacteria but virtually all bacteria
encode enzymes like this not all of them
produce sea Camp the one I'm talking
about today does but many other cdntases
produce diverse nucleotide second
messengers they had all broadly conform
to this same function
so we knew based on the structural
homology that there was a lot of
similarity between sea gas and mammals
and CD antiases and bacteria but in 2019
uh two different groups both arrived at
the same finding that really um
solidified this shared evolutionary
history uh that was uh rhodium sorics
group in a paper led by Cohen and
malamed as well as um in this paper from
Kevin Corbett's group both uh Labs
identified that sea gas-like enzymes or
cdntases are anti-fage and in that way
seagas is antiviral in both Kingdoms of
Life
now the the mechanism of sensing and
signaling diverges a little bit but it's
still very similar a stimulus in this
case phage infection and bacteria
activates a synthase to produce a
nucleotide second messenger and that
ultimately restricts viral replication
in bacteria it's not double-stranded DNA
that's sensed and that makes sense
because bacteria don't compartmentalize
their DNA in a nucleus so DNA in the
cytosol isn't necessarily a danger
signal we don't understand this sensing
although we're actively working on it
the cdntas still produces a nucleotide
second messenger and the way that the
nucleotide second messenger signals in
bacteria is that it coordinates a
program cell death response generally
through an effector that program cell
death is called abortive infection and
it's essentially an infected bacteria
committing suicide and the reasoning
behind that is because when a cell knows
it's infected with a phage by committing
suicide It ultimately restricts virion
production and this is a
uh altruistic activity because while the
infected bacterium sort of takes one for
the team by uh committing suicide and
restricting virion production it saves
the whole population
this relationship between sea gas and
bacteria sea gas and mammals and both
being antiviral uh really fascinated me
and and so my lab is interested in the
molecular mechanism of how this phage
resistance is coordinated by the cdntas
by cdamp and ultimately I'm hoping in
the next
um in the future we'll be able to fill
in a lot of the dotted lines here today
the molecular mechanism that I'm going
to describe is how this cdntas is
regulated
so in order to understand this pathway
what we've done is we've reconstructed a
system from vibrio cholera in lab E coli
the fact that the system is from River
of Cholera is not that relevant it's
actually very similar to other systems
that are found in E coli but what you
have to understand about anti-phage
systems or defense systems broadly is
that they move around on mobile genetic
elements so they're actually able to
function in many diverse environments
often in related bacteria so in this
case we're taking a system out of gamma
proteobacteria and we're reconstructing
it in E coli
we call it a system this cdntase because
it exists in an operon and this is a
system that was dubbed cyclic uh
nucleotide based anti-phage signaling
systems or sea bass
and in our case the cdntase operon that
we're working on is a forging system so
we've cloned that system into a vector
in order to study the anti-phage
signaling and now what we can do is we
can introduce that Vector into E coli
the first Gene other than the cdntas
which happens to be the second Gene in
the operon is called CAP V and this is
what we dubbed the effector it's the
seagamp receptor that ultimately
coordinates program cell death because
when seagamp binds cap V it destroys the
membrane and so that's that abortive
infection that I told you about in
addition to cat V and the CD nth there's
two genes of unknown function cap2 and
cap three
what we do is we transform this Vector
into lab E coli mg1655 E coli we then
embed those E coli in a soft auger
overlay on top of a conventional auger
plate
and we challenge those bacteria with
phages simply by spotting phage
dilutions on top of that plate
here's what the data for that actually
looks like so what we're looking at is
we're looking down on a plate and we're
looking at the soft dogger overlay
that's on top of the nutrient auger and
we've spotted different phage dilutions
now going from a very concentrated to a
very dilute amount
this measurement is called an efficiency
of plating and what you can see are
these little black spots and each one of
those black spots is a place where a
phage virion landed infect a bacterium
and went through subsequent rounds of
replication in order to produce a zone
of clearance and so one plaque came from
one virion we call this a platforming
unit and it's just like the colony
forming units that we think of for
bacteria
we're using phage T2 and you can see
that this phage readily forms a plaque
when we infect bacteria that are
transformed with an empty Vector but if
we transform them with a cdntase operon
encoding Vector you can see a large
restriction in the the number of pfu
able to form in fact even at the most
concentrated amounts of phage we don't
see nice clear plaques forming we see
this little Halo and we think that's
probably just bacteria being killed
through that abortive infection
this is the phage defense and it's over
four logs of of Defense in uh plating
efficiency and all of that is dependent
on the active site of the sea gas-like
enzyme so here the cdntas with a did to
AIA mutation uh completely ablates our
phenotype so everything's dependent on
the cdntas
we really wanted to understand what was
going on here and so we started with the
cdntas and we started by simply
immunoprecipitating that enzyme and
seeing what other proteins might be
interacting
to do this we appended an n-terminal
vsvg tag onto the cdntas and then
immunoprecipitated from bacteria
followed by tryptic digest and mass spec
and what we're comparing is an IP an
immunoprecipitation from a
bacterium expressing the full cdntase
operon with the vsvg tag or the operon
without a vsvg tag this is our negative
control and when we do that we look at
the proteins identified by our triptych
Mass Spec what you can see is
predictably the cdntas is highly
enriched in in this experiment and that
makes sense
but also enriched
um and and perhaps the next most
enriched protein was cap2 that was that
Gene of unknown function that I had uh
pointed out was also in the operon
um and so in this way I think we did a
very complicated analysis in order to
Simply find the adjacently encoded Gene
seem to be interacting with the cdntas
in data that I'm not showing you we've
done reciprocal IPS where we can pull on
cap2 and immunoprecipitate the cdntas
and vice versa we can immunoprecipitate
the cdntas and and pull down cap2 so
they appear to be forming some sort of a
complex
and to better understand that
we worked with uh the lab of uh Dr Kevin
Corbett at UC San Diego to determine the
crystal structure or sorry to determine
the structure um by cryolian this has
been a really fantastic collaboration
um with Kevin over the years and uh what
what Kevin's lab was able to do was
first to purify the cdntas complex by
size exclusion and then to look at the
how these two interacted on a structural
level
uh the structure that they determined uh
was at 2.7 angstroms and it it broadly
looked like this and I know that it's
um very complicated there's already a
lot of color so I want to walk you
through this this structure
um but the first thing that we found was
that it was a 2-2 complex so there were
two proteins of cap2 and two monomers of
the CD ntas that were in this sort of
interesting figure eight conformation
by just focusing first on cap2 so I'm
graying out the the CD ntas in this
structure what we could tell was that
cap2 had two different protein domains
one domain had homology to an E1 enzyme
and the other etymology to an E2 with a
very uh interesting Linker in between
the E1 domains formed a dimer and and
this dimer is sort of interesting you
can imagine if your hands were capped
too and then you pressed your palms
together the E1 domains are the palms
and the E2 domains of the fingers and
and your fingers as they ramp down
um actually show you that the E2 domain
of one monomer interacts with the E1
domain of the other monomer so it's a
really interesting configuration and
this has been seen before for other E1
enzymes that's because E1 and E2 like
enzymes have been studied for a long
time because they're the principal
component of the ubiquitin transferase
Machinery that's found in eukaryotes
this was really cool to find in a
bacteria bacteria have homologs of E1
enzymes that are core components of
molybdoterrin biosynthesis Pathways or a
couple other biosynthesis Pathways
um but this was the first E1 uh E2
fusion protein that had really been
investigated and identified
um and it was just exciting because here
we were working on something that's sea
gas like and now we have something
that's ubiquitin transferase like
so ubiquitination just to refresh
everyone's memory from your cell bio 101
class
um starts with an E1 enzyme that
ampolates ubiquitin which is a small
protein modifier used ubiquitously uh
within eukaryotic cells
E1 forms a thioester with ubiquitin and
then it shuttles that thioester
activated ubiquitin onto an E2 protein
where it forms another thioester on a
different cysteine
and E3 is used in conjunction with an E2
to then ultimately transfer the
ubiquitin onto some substrate and that's
typically on a lysine side chain
here we found a fusion protein cap2 has
an n-terminal E2 and a c terminal E1
complete with the ampellation active
site and it looked like it was poised to
do some sort of transferase reaction
if we now broaden our our what we're
looking at to look at the hole structure
not just the cap2 portion what I hope
you can appreciate is that the cdntas
bridges the E1 and the E2 domains and in
fact it it's very close in proximity to
the active sites of these E1 and E2
domains which are very close to each
other
bacteria or at least in this case we we
now have an E1 we have an E2 domain in
this fusion protein
um but I I think I mentioned that uh at
least in E coli where where we're
looking there aren't E3 homologs
um there aren't beta grasp ubiquitin
homologs uh that are Standalone in the
way we think about ubiquitin and so we
were struggling to understand what it
was that cap2 could be doing and what
this complex with the cdntase was really
teaching us
um and it was at that time uh when we
were able to look closely and the
structure told us a lot more about what
was happening
by focusing on that E1 and E2 active
site which were inactive in the uh
enzymes that we ultimately determine the
structure of
what we could see was the c-terminus of
the cdntas
was uh in the E1 and the E2 active site
and on the c-terminal residue what we
saw was an amp molecule had already been
added this is exactly how ubiquitin is
transferred it starts with ampolation of
the c-terminus of the ubiquitin prior to
those thioester bonds being formed and
this really planted the idea in our head
that perhaps the cdntase is serving as
the ubiquitin as it were for cap2
mediated transfer
so
um the question was is this really going
on in Vivo though that the structural
evidence was very solid and I'm not
showing you this superimposed with
ubiquitin or with any of the um other uh
systems that are highly homologous here
um but the way we went about
testing some of these hypotheses that
I've been introducing is to return to
our phage system
so by by going back and now uh looking
at cap2 and introducing mutations uh
what we did was we measured phage
resistance when we inactivated many of
the important features that we saw in
our structure
here what I'm showing you is uh now
phage resistance in bar graph form so
rather than looking at pictures of
plates I'm going to quantify and
transform that data along the y-axis
we're looking at phage T2 protection so
this is just dividing uh uninfected
versus or sorry unprotected versus
protected uh strains of E coli
expressing different uh cdntase operon
alleles
uh and what you can see here along the
x-axis is that when you express the wild
type system you see about four logs of
protection so robust anti-phase
protection however if you delete cap2
you now fully ablate that so the the
unprotected system in this graph would
be at 10 to the zero would be at one
so everything's dependent on cap2 and
also phage defense is dependent on the
adenylation active site the E1 active
site cysteine and the E2 active site
cysteine
similarly if we now mutate the cdntas
what we can see is wild type again
produces robust uh protection a
catalytically inactivating mutation like
the one I showed you earlier ablates
protection but introduction of a uh C
terminal bulky residue so here the C
Terminus ends in a glycine which is
nicely accommodated by the E1 E2 active
site if we simply substitute that for
glutamate now we can completely ablate
protection and what we think is going on
here is the cdntac Terminus isn't able
to insert into that active site
so the hypothesis now is that cap2 is
our transferase and it's using a CD ntas
like ubiquitin and if that's the case we
should be able to do Western blondes
four cdntas in bacteria expressing the
full system and see something akin to
ubiquitin blocks that you would expect
to see in mammalian cells and so we did
just that
here I'm showing you an immunoblot
that's anti-cd NTA so we raised an
antibody against this cdntas and for
bacteria expressing an empty Vector we
see some amount of background but now in
bacteria expressing the wild type system
we see not only monomeric cdntas but
also these high molecular weight species
we can then
in this system use our different mutant
cdnts operons and what we find is those
High molecular weight species are
dependent on adenylation on the E1
active site and on the E2 active site
this really
um bolstered our our confidence in this
hypothesis that cap2 is using the
cdntas's ubiquitin and it's conjugating
the cdntas to some Target now as you can
see uh there's many different bands and
I'll just say right now we don't
understand what the targets are we're
actively working on it we're excited by
it it doesn't seem um to be as simple as
there's one dominant Target so it could
be that there are multiple targets or it
could be that there are multiple copies
of the CD ntas added to each other in a
manner kind of like ubiquitin we don't
favor that hypothesis but we haven't yet
ruled it out and we're actively now
trying to do Mass Spec and see exactly
what these species are although it's
proving rather challenging
so what's really stumped Us in this
analysis though is the why of it all
which is always a question that you can
ask in order to get yourself in trouble
but
why is this uh cap2 using the cdntas's
ubiquitin what's the function of
creating these cdntas conjugates that
are higher molecular weight well we
hypothesize that perhaps since the
cdntase is an enzyme by conjugating it
to some Target we're changing
um the enzymology of how the cdnth
synthesizes seagamp perhaps now it's
more capable to produce seagamp and in
that way more poised to restrict phage
in order to ask that question we return
to our immunoprecipitation we uh
appended our vsvg tag onto the
n-terminus of the cdntas I'm not showing
you this but all the tags that we use
are functional in our phage resistance
assay
and in this way now we should be able to
immunoprecipitate the cdntas along with
its Target and if it's this target
conjugation is changing the rate of CD
of uh seagam synthesis we should be able
to measure that in vitro by incubating
these conjugates with ATP and GTP which
is what cdamp is synthesized from
here along the y-axis we're measuring
the amount of c-gam that's been
generated uh we're using uh what's
basically an Elisa assay for sea gamp
that's been synthesized in vitro
and along the x-axis I'm showing you the
different genotypes of bacteria that we
immunoprecipitated the cdntas from so
when we express a wild type CD and Tas
operon with no vs VG tag we don't pull
down any cdntas so we get no detectable
c-gamp so that's our Baseline but when
we engineer in that vsvg tag now we can
see robust production of uh the the
seagamp from our wild type system
if we catalytically inactivate the CD
ntas we see no seagamp synthesized so so
this really
um is about validating the assay
and of course you probably figured out
because I'm showing you this that when
you mutate the active site of cap2 here
mutating the active site E1 system or E2
cysteine you can see a loss in seagamp
synthesis so this is about the cdntas
producing less C Camp even in vitro
we did all of these experiments in the
absence of phage but we expected that uh
if we were to now add phage or
immunoprecipitate from phage infected
bacteria that we should be able to
increase the production of sea Camp if
this is about sensing phage
however when we do that experiment and
now we look at secant generated from
immunoprecipitated cdntas either from
uninfected or infected bacteria we don't
see a change in the amount of secant
that's being synthesized and so for that
reason we think this is really about
um what's going on before infection and
I like to use the term priming or
otherwise licensing the system it
appears that cap2 is modifying the cdnts
in such a way that now it's 100
necessary for defense against phage but
it's not necessarily responding to phage
or the other way to think about that is
the phage q that would otherwise turn
this system on Still Remains to be seen
so
um all of these data are are available
in this bio archive preprint and I just
want to go over the model of what I've
shown you today uh we have in in
bacteria a uninfected or an inactive
cdntas that is primed through the action
of cap2 and that's through ligation to
some Target in the formation of higher
molecular weight species
that we know is insufficient for full
activation of the system there's still
some viral cue something that says
there's a phage here and while we can
see evidence for this priming in vitro
we don't see uh this producing in Vivo
seagamp because in vivocamp ultimately
leads to abortive infection and effector
activation and that in Vivo and vitro
divide uh is probably telling us
something about what's going on here and
how the phage is perhaps depleting some
inhibitor of the cdntas which is why
it's active in vitro but inactive in
Vivo that remains to be seen
what I haven't talked to you about
though is this last protein here cap3 so
uh to to back up one
this really came down to regulation of
the cdntas and in cap2 appears to
regulate the CD ntas in a manner not so
dissimilar from how eukaryotes highly
regulate their innate immune system and
in fact in that system often ubiquitin
is a very potent way to regulate
mammalian innate immune sensors but
whenever there's an on switch As for
cap2 turning things on there should also
be some off switch that is
de-ubiquitinating or DCd anti-isolating
some Target and that's what we found
cap3 is doing so I don't really have
time to get into all the data but I'll
just show you that we think cap3 is
removing the cdntas from targets
our evidence for that is that if we look
again at those cdntase conjugates we see
that we can remove them by expressing
cap three which is predicted to be a
protease a jab family protease and is
also requires the active site residues
of cap3 so a catalytically inactivating
mutation ablates this phenotype
similarly if we return to our in vitro
seagamp synthesis assay in the absence
of cap3 we now see more secant being
generated
indicating that the abundance of the
Prime CD nth goes up in the absence of
cat 3.
so in terms of future directions and
what my lab is actively working on we're
really focused on I think two main
questions
uh one what are the the target uh that
the cdntas is being ligated to that that
really is coordinating this priming and
two
what is this phage queue truth be told
when we started out looking at this
project that's we started looking for
the phage queue
um and then found ourselves working on
this ubiquin nation system uh that's
just been so fascinating but I think
there's still so much to be learned
about what is the
um pathogen Associated molecular pattern
or what is the signature of viral
infection that turns the whole thing on
and of course what I'd really like to
know is is that same amp or signal also
detected in mammalian cells if that's a
question that also interests you
um feel free to shoot me an email and uh
and talk about perhaps doing a postdoc
in the lab
the last thing I want to leave you with
today in just one more minute is a brand
new finding that I I think is
fascinating and hopefully you'll also
find interesting
um we we've started uh getting serious
about some of the bioinformatic analyzes
to not just look at cap2 and cap three
in our cdnta system but where else do we
find these ubiquitin transferase like
enzymes thankfully much of those
bioinformatics have been previously
published by the Arvin group including
work by Maxwell Burroughs
and what they found are actually other
systems where cap2 and cap3 have been
reformulated not with cdntases but with
other genes that uh look like defense
systems and when we look at those
operons here I'm just showing you a
snapshot of those
um from from these papers uh or
otherwise identified by us
what I hope you can see is that there
are many different formulations and and
fusion proteins of cap2 like enzymes and
cap3 like enzymes but perhaps most
excitingly when we really dig into
what's in these different operons
what we find is that many of them encode
beta grasp folds or beta grass-fold
proteins and that's the same fold that
we find in ubiquitin in fact many of
these systems look like they encode
tandem beta grasp fold proteins just
like how ubiquitin is encoded in tandem
in the mammalian germ line
we're just beginning to think about you
know what's even the hypothesis for how
a ubiquitin-like modifier would be used
in this system because bacteria don't
have proteosomes this isn't just a
ubiquitin proteosome shuttling things
for degradation so we're trying to
understand how this could be antiviral
but I think it's just has really
exciting uh consequences for our
understanding of ubiquitin signaling of
virology
um and of course of just the evolution
of all of this as we move between
bacteria and eukaryotes and with that I
should probably go ahead and stop but I
just want to thank all the people who
helped make this possible
um I'm really fortunate in my lab to
work with a lot of really talented
people who I've listed here but
especially uh Dr Hannah ledvin as a
postdoc who led all of this work
um in in our lab and then of course our
collaboration with uh Kevin Corbett at
UC San Diego
um made all of the structural biology
possible and has been really fruitful
and and that work was led by xiaozan Yi
um I of course want to thank our funding
um and uh point out that our
um oh you can't see my cursor but our
lab is just out of frame
um in this uh picture and uh if you have
any questions I won't be available to
answer them here
um but please feel free to shoot me an
email and keep the discussion going
um thank you very much